what would you say the bulk of the 25
000 that you raised for walter on
kickstarter
was spent on so the bulk of the the
money raised on
kickstarter uh was definitely spent on
this academy qualifying campaign
and specifically the commercial releases
in new york and la
uh there are ways to for wall commercial
release
and we are for four well in our
commercial release so
um which is tough because you walk into
la new york in our specific case
it's going to be a little different
depending on if you're getting daytime
slots or
evening slots but as of right now i mean
it's
you know you're looking at probably
twelve thousand dollars to
twenty thousand dollars somewhere in
that range in order to
be able to secure those two locations
for one week and
and you're talking anywhere i mean
you're talking like 14 to 21 screenings
at each location
for that kind of money so if you've got
a film that's not going to get a lot of
audience and we know going into it we're
not going to get a ton of audience doing
it you're not going to see much of that
money come back
that's just money that poofs away but
that money comes back in interesting
ways and this gets back to the idea of
investing for the long term thinking
about the long term
this is an experiment so i can't speak
for sure about this
but my feeling is by giving the film
a little bit of a bigger richer context
from the beginning
um sort of polishing it up and having it
be this type of film that has
reviews whether they're good or not you
know it's got these reviews it's got
bigger press
and it will ultimately help shape the
film
for some bigger sales down the road so i
think that money will come back
that's my prediction and we'll you know
i'm happy to check back with you guys
but it's pretty scary when you're like
you know writing these checks and you go
well
shoot for you know fifteen thousand
dollars
i could put on a heck of a good tour and
go to places where we know we could
probably fill the theaters
and make all that money back and more
and then put that to the film to go
forward
but you'll get a bunch of reviews in
like small towns like great falls which
are great and
they always feel really good but they
don't necessarily speak
to the film industry and allow you this
film you know the film based
opportunities where people want the film
and help
sell it further on down the road so when
you were calling
these theaters in la and new york were
you going based on price
or were you going based on which ones
actually had
ends with getting those reviews in new
york times valley times what was your
strategy
so our strategy when we set up our
commercial releases in new york and la
was
first to kind of research and see if
other people had done this which which
they had so i started to realize there's
actually people
that will help broker the deal for you
so if you google around
yeah you'll find somebody who can kind
of help you
and it's all part of a package price i
actually went direct to ifc center
and said hey because i'd seen an article
ifc center
helps films qualify for academy awards
meaning they will book a
book a film at a four-wall prize
for you know for a week meaning you
don't have to go through this weird
convoluted system i still haven't
figured out to get a booker to consider
your film to get it out there you know
i'm starting to realize as i do this
more and more it is very controlled by
the studios or the distributors that
have the money to market these films so
for somebody that's you know smaller and
has smaller films and doesn't
necessarily have a ton of money for pna
it's going to be very difficult for you
to get like conventional theatrical
releases out there but there are these
smaller art houses
that are starting to realize that in new
york and la and
and for a certain certain kind of price
you can get in so i went to ifc center
first
talked to um talked to a guy there about
what it would cost and he started to run
some numbers and i think it was like
around
you know 6 500 for their lowest package
which is
day daytime daytime screenings you know
you have to be within a certain window
to qualify it has to be after one
o'clock so it's not like
10 a.m screenings but it's still like
you're talking about
like pretty early screenings you could
have a 115 and a 315 screening for your
movie you know and that's your
that's your theatrical launch you know
we're in a situation where we're like
well we want an evening slot we want to
definitely have that evening feel for
the film and have
you know some people that we know in the
industry and some of some other people
show up and see the film so we
negotiated we ended up working with a
guy in la that set up both ifc center
and and a theater chain here called
lamle
that would you know ultimately launch
our film um for
you know the right kind of times that we
liked so we paid a little a little extra
to get
some better times but i think we're
definitely happy to have done that just
have had that experience and you know
and uh and we actually used the
kickstarter experience and brought it
back i mean we had
we had people that that uh contributed
to be part of our premieres uh out in
new york that showed up and we got to
meet these new people and you know they
became
i think hopefully deeper fans you know
they it seems that they were happy with
the fact that they put
money into helping make this possible
but that ultimately kind of helped us
feel like we could throw a little bit of
party and have a
have a fun launch out there in new york
and uh so that was pretty cool
to see that see that play itself out so
you ultimately did go with a booker
in the end yeah we did yeah you did
uh-huh okay
and they've been you know it's been an
interesting experience working with
with a booker you know and you're kind
of trying to figure out the system and
how they're talking about this or that
and you know we're dealing with
something now where they're trying to
switch us out possibly with a different
theater here so that's a little bit
that's a little bit of a challenge last
minute you know seeing seeing
seeing that happen um and i don't know
if the academy
wants it that way who knows you know
that's something i'm curious about i
i've definitely toyed with the idea of
how how transparent like sarah and i are
going to be about here's what our
experience was like i mean it's
definitely been an up and down battle
it's been one of those things where it's
like man
we should should we really be spending
the money this way you know it's
definitely something we think about but
i
i have convinced myself and i do feel
like it is nice to have a legitimate
release for a film um and to put the
money into that but
you know you do there's a point where
you have to think about like if you're
spending
you know fifteen thousand plus all the
other expenses for travel and all this
other stuff so over twenty thousand
dollars to do something
but you're not really seeing much money
come back does that i mean economically
doesn't make any sense
in that moment again we'll see down the
road
with a little bit of smoke and mirrors
you never know you know and
you know somehow if if if there was ever
a chance that we'd get nominated or even
shortlisted it would definitely give us
you know some attention
um and even if it didn't doesn't happen
on this film but maybe it introduces us
to the right people and it helps us down
the road on another film
you know maybe that was that was a
gamble that was worth it so
that's that's the way i look at it you
know i i kind of look back to
the kickstarter moment this is what we
told people we're going to do that's
what we
you know that's we built our campaign
around and we want to see it through so
you know chalk it up to that and in the
end you didn't leave these jobs just to
make something and and just put it up on
youtube and in the very end i mean you
you want that press you want that those
two even if some of it is smoke and
mirrors which are probably
so many filmmakers it is but still i
mean
that's why you took that big leap and
that's why she did so i think that
it's probably hard in the moment to you
know
see those numbers but then you don't
know down the line it is hard at the
moment but there's
there's that point there's those points
in your career where you shouldn't be
afraid to make those and sometimes
that's leaving the day job for a while
like we talked about earlier
you know when i look look at all these
points where i've taken risks
like there's really not any time where i
look back and go darn it why'd i do that
you know
sometimes it's hard in the moment like i
feel the difficulty of spending
all this money on this launch but um
i realize like it's allowing me to be
here i'm taking as many meetings as i
can i'm you know
reconnecting with uh many filmmakers or
many people in the industry that i've
known
over the years and so there's other ways
where you see the benefit of something
or do for taking this
this crazy action that's a little scary
you know a little risky
um and you never know how it's gonna how
it's gonna pan itself out
right and sometimes playing it safe can
hurt someone
yeah you know yeah definitely i mean
there's many times where i'm timid and
shy and i play it safe and i'm like wow
nothing's happening well
this is you know you can just feel
yourself becoming a little less relevant
so then you find ways to to step it up
and i'm just grateful that i'm at a
point where
there's a there is a crowd there's this
idea that people can come together
and help collectively you know
help you take that step you know have
that confidence i think if people
you know continue to approach it that
way but not you know
you know not you know not abuse that i
mean it's something i take pretty
seriously if
if i'm raising money from fans and
friends and family like
i want to do everything i can to come
through for them
and give them something awesome and i
think unfortunately there's a lot of
people that probably don't
don't do that